well there there have been Ponzi schemes
throughout history he was bigger more
brazen more remarkable because of his
capacity to survive even when the SEC
had supposedly taken a hard look at him
on numerous occasions and so yes I think
he will become the his name alone will
come to typify and capture an era of
irresponsibility and lack of allegiance
to the two simple principles of
integrity in the marketplace now he also
stands for that the abject failure of
the SEC during my years as Attorney
General I was very critical of the SEC
because it didn't make sense that the
Attorney General of New York was
bringing the sorts of cases that we were
bringing the SEC should have been there
doing what we were doing but they were
both ideologically opposed and actually
intellectually incapable of doing what
they were supposed to do there there was
a lethargy that there there was a
hesitancy that there there was a failure
of intellect that was hard to to get my
arms around when Harvey Pitts came in as
chair of the FCC he said to the world to
the investment bankers he said you will
find a kinder gentler SEC that's
ridiculous and I said to him we don't
want a kind and gentler enforcer of the
marketplace we want somebody who's fair
but rigorous tough and and understands
how to ensure integrity in the
marketplace but that was typical of what
began with President Reagan continued
through President Bush and so we needed
to unwind that that that failure of
regulatory backbone
well look uh we were doing everything we
could we brought the systemic cases
against analysts insurance mutual funds
on and on and on
I'd never heard Bernie Madoff name and I
wish I had I wish we had were aware of
him had anybody take anybody sensible
taken in a quick look at his structure
you would have realized a the trades
that he pretended to have made simply
couldn't fit within the market space he
was talking about and had you even
looked to see and it said I want one day
of trading records and then I want to
know who your custodian is where do you
actually who keeps these shares you
would have found out the whole thing was
a scam so it would have been the
simplest investigation in the world I
just you know II never heard of them